en ces temps de pandémie une attention
exceptionnelle est porté à l'actualité
scientifique et tout particulièrement à
la recherche d'un vaccin
ce précieux traitement qui
transformerait la menace du commis de 19
et ses conséquences en un lointain
souvenir et la star pharmaceutiques du
moment c'est moderna therapeutics une
société américaine de biotechnologie
d'une dizaine d'années installé à boston
et dirigé cocorico par le français
stéphane bancel
un ancien cadre du laboratoire lyonnais
biomérieux et 6 modern a fait autant
parler d'elle c'est parce qu'elle a
annoncé il ya quelques jours avoir
finalisé le protocole de la troisième
phase de l'essai clinique d'un vaccin
contre le coronavirus la troisième et
donc dernière phase avant de soumettre
son produit aux autorités de
réglementation le vaccin développé par
moderna le mrn à 12,73 est comme son nom
indique un vaccin à arn messagers soit
un type de traitement encore jamais
éprouvé jusque là sur l'homme
si cette solution s'avérait être la
bonne elle ouvrirait la porte à une
nouvelle ère de la vaccination
problème il semblerait que moderna aille
un peu vite en besogne
le 18 mai dernier la société annonçait
les résultats positifs selon elle de la
première phase d'essais cliniques de son
vaccin
sauf que les données étaient très
lacunaire et ne concernait que huit
patients sur les 45 tester la phase iii
quand elle est déjà annoncée alors que
la phase ii n'est même pas terminée un
calendrier très serré donc pour le
développement d'un vaccin qui a commencé
début janvier et qui ne plaît guère à
certains spécialistes les résultats
scientifiques doivent pouvoir être
examiné en détail par des pairs pour
tester leur validité
l' usage de communiqués de presse
surtout s'il ne précède pas
immédiatement une publication
scientifique est une pratique nouvelle
qui met à mal l'éthique de la recherche
moderna n'est pas la seule entreprise de
la santé à chercher un traitement contre
le coronavirus au 9 juin dernier selon
le ms les laboratoires du monde entier
plancher sur quelque 136 vaccins
potentiels dont dix sont actuellement en
phase d'essais cliniques
une course effrénée à la recherche d'un
traitement qui revêt un enjeu financier
co
salle moderna a déjà reçu 4 183 millions
de dollars de subventions pour accélérer
le développement de son vaccin et mieux
encore le jour de l'annoncé des premiers
résultats sa valeur en bourse s'envolait
de 30% et quelques jours plus tard
modern a levé 1,34 milliard de dollars
sur les marchés pour financer le produit
miracle
alors est-ce que moderna therapeutics
livrera bien un vaccin en janvier 2021
soit l'objectif fixé par washington
ce qui est certain c'est que le labo de
bust maîtrise sa communication et c'est
la mettre à profit les 18 et 19 mai ses
dirigeants ont vendu des centaines de
milliers d'actions pour des dizaines de
millions de dollars de bénéfices un
succès financier purement spéculatif si
l'on en croit bruno pitard directeur de
recherche au cnrs la pandémie crée des
opportunités et moderna est un champion
qui suscite beaucoup d'espoir celui
d'avoir un vaccin est celui que les
titres achetés valence 8 plus cher mais
dans la biotech c'est toujours comme ça
c'est une bulle moderna surf sur le fait
qu'elle mène la course pour le grand
public comme pour les professionnels
qu'il s'agisse de moderna de la première
étude du dr house ou de la récente
publication du land 7
il semble urgent de prendre son temps
lorsqu'il s'agit de santé et ne pas
céder à l'illusion du remède miracle